The content creators that I feel are so fucking valuable right now
are the child free women who are posting about their life.
Because as a child of 80s and elder millennial,
I didn't feel like I had an option.
I felt like the only way I was gonna be happy was if I had kids.
And so I had kids. Um,
I had four kids. And
I didn't have an example of happy child free women.
I had child free women in my life.
My godmother's child free.
The reason she's my godmother is because my mother felt so bad for her
that she couldn't have children
that she made her my godmother
so that maybe she could share the gift of motherhood with her.
And that woman was not. I haven't talked to her in like,
I don't even know when's the last time I talked to her,
when she didn't give a fuck.
Like there was nothing you could give her
that was gonna fill that hole of motherhood.
And I just wish more women truly understood
that motherhood is not all that is fucking cracked up to be.
It's not Fucking Pinterest.
And I'm not saying that like I'm some fucking pink tote mom. As,
as far as my children know,
they are my whole entire world.
I love them, I give them everything that I can.
I, you know what I mean?
Like, it's not
some Nurse Hannah situation over here.
It's just the reality.
That motherhood is not all that it's cracked up to be.
It's not all that people make it out to be.
It's not.
For as rewarding as it is,
it's also that painful, it hurts.
There's.
There's also stress. It's just.
It's not Pinterest. It's not what you thought it was.
And it's important to see that
you absolutely can be happy without having children.
You don't have to have children to be happy.
You also don't have to have children
to have the love of children in your life.
I have several friends in my life that are child free
and they babysit my kids or they come over or whatever, and,
you know, they get the experience of children
and the children are way more excited to see them
cause they usually have way cooler stories to tell them than me,
their mom. So to all the women who are producing content,
child free content, your voice is so valuable.
And thank you.